citizens of the reject Nation we are
going to watch DC League of Super Pets
today I'm joined by koi the genre so
excited first one of these um
this better be a good one was gonna go
watch us in the theaters he literally
stopped me stop what you're doing go
watch bodies bodies we are reacting to
TC League of Super Pets haven't opened
and he was like you stop right now I
undid my ticket and I body body bodied
and now here we are a couple weeks later
and I'm excited to watch this movie so
guys please leave a like that'd be super
appreciated subscribe and click that
notification Bell get notified when our
next movie reaction is up he's got a
movie reaction for a film you won't
believe you won't believe but he already
filmed it and I was shocked to learn
that he had not seen this movie and I
was like we're gonna film a reaction for
us also follow corjandro Tick Tock 15
ticket 30 second three minute videos
white ass bullying through action watch
long as we single with your own copy for
DC League of Super Pets over at our
patreon for super sexy rejects cover a
bunch of shows exclusively over there
reaction highlights and watch songs
included team forever thank this down a
lot let's get to it
[Music]
[Music]
I mean well it's adorable
that's how he got his hair curl Krypton
is about to die
you dear son will live on
they don't even give a [ __ ] about the
dog the dog likes screw it
cold-blooded
correct watch over our son
foreign
[Music]
that's why you need a puppy
[Music]
this is so sweet
all right wake up buddy it is walk a
clock okay
all right
five more minutes
and I'm up Superman's lazy he's known
for it
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
we never lose one
[Music]
[Laughter]
classic
precious
[Music]
laughs
such a good little sad joke
turns out you just didn't say his name
backwards you think I'm cute
are we looking faces right now because
if we're looking faces I gotta get in on
him
what do I have here
squeezy Bruce
[Laughter]
we see Bruce retreat
hey those guys look fun how about you go
play with them
he's gonna kill those dogs just murder
those squeezy Bruce he's trying to get
rid of you what that's ridiculous
Superman and I are inseparable where you
were sleeping these days I sleep in bed
with soups except when Lois stays over
then I have to move to my extra special
spot on the floor
I mean sure the guy dates but he will
never love anyone except for more
oh
[Laughter]
man finds new best friend you're my best
friends dummies and you're all coming
with me to the farm I love when he talks
about the farm well one day
when the stars align the device will
bring me ultimate power and I will be
more than free
all right boys I'll be right back with a
surprise and I will remain here posing
under my secret identity can that caller
actually hold him I bet the FedEx guy
the other day ah fine job who was he
working for General Zod the Legion of
Doom
FedEx
there we go
[Music]
[Applause]
ouch I'm kind of in the middle of a
prison break so could you please Prison
Break stop right there and cease your
unlawful activities dog I've never met
heck are you talking about man you the
same dog that was literally just behind
me that dog wore glasses
[Laughter]
soups is probably missing me the dude
tied you up to the stop sign and went
into that shelter to buy you a new
friend so did you give them some space
Superman would never do that well it's
literally happening right now I'm just
glad that that new friend ain't me
crypto's having an internal crisis
existential journey of what it is to be
a super dog
don't get your hopes up they always pick
a kid
here you go baby
stay being a rescuer
[Music]
[Laughter]
someone is dragging a meteor toward the
city
Krasinski is a good voice for Superman
it's pretty great
I like the little gravel he's adding
[ __ ]
[Music]
[Applause]
bam baby Superman's a menace I really
like the animation a lot it's really fun
[Music]
I have friends thanks for building
yourself oh my God I'm Aquaman oh great
these jabronis uh did somebody call tech
support have you tried turning it off
and on again
oh my there's an old Justice League
please fasten your safety belts they are
invisible
I like your laser thing what
don't know which Green Lantern that's
supposed to be the woke one
all I need is one little piece
yay
I am but I was always meant to become
I'm supposed to have super powers
they're overrated yes
I miss my parents
oh so good she might be Jessica Cruz
Green Lantern look
I failed this city
hello gorgeous
oh how I've longed for you to enter my
solar system
is a genius guinea pig of Doom I do like
the animation style it's got like that
classic comic strip vibe to it like from
the 50s I like that the the background
stuff's all really detailed in texture
but then there's like a simpleness to
the characters and we had a plan until
crypto the Superdog had to come and ruin
it stupid name
you're welcome
oh you're the sweetest and have me winch
orange Kryptonite it doesn't work on
people it only works
on pets no way is this Canon I mean
obviously orange Kryptonite and pets
goes back to the 40s
uh Lulu are you okay I am what I was
always meant to become
look at Jean Gray Carrie guinea pig you
know we we gotta stick together right
solidarity oh Ace I'm sorry I don't
really have time in my life right now to
take care of a pet
I like the Wayne Tech on a bunch of
stuff yeah what about me
I'm not a monster
hi even she takes the cat
I'm gonna get us out
is my mouth watering there's so much to
unpack here
what
[Music]
holy [ __ ]
you're invulnerable and I can trick
myself down to the size of it
yikes
this is the most dangerous Metropolis
has ever been yes pure chaos this is
like eight episodes of small villain one
yeah
I'm the only one who didn't get any
superpower because they're Speedy time
for my favorite show with my bro in my
tropo let me just
out oh she call me Iron Man huh pretty
dressed up for the British Bake Off
oh you have a date
on Bake Off Night Ultimate betrayal
bad dog
that is way out of line fella I mean if
you want to talk about this when I get
home
I've missed you so much
squeezy Bruce and
the bad owner
[Music]
[Laughter]
aren't you the hamster from the shelter
I am a guinea pig and I said Neil
[Music]
wow that's all it took that's it
you really should have made it harder to
find you those glasses aren't fooling
anyone mustache maybe but not glasses
good job Warner Brothers I respect you
[Music]
you always
[Laughter]
this is The Rock when he has a box
office bomb
surrender I don't want to hurt you no no
no
a little advice never tested guinea pig
ever test a guinea pig
's a little cooler than I thought it
would be
they're going places like striking
oh he left me cheese
Superman ain't no way
[Applause]
ouch
wait what's going on [ __ ] tonight maybe
it's like because he's near it tiny
shout of green Kryptonite cleverly
concealed in a hunk of yarl's bird we
got it they always put it in the cheese
the Hooves and the cheese
I thought it was just proximity that
makes more sense
I like that porn
[ __ ]
Superman I have to fight oh oh I didn't
love that sound work
ouch
yes
it's not superpowers that make you a
hero crypto that's not your problem your
problem is you mate you what do you mean
me father
hero's journey for the dog
oh damn that dog messed up
I was just uh hit by a car a little
you never forget your first time
[Laughter]
you Hooligans can help me we have to
save Superman crebo Crisco who's your
name no it's Crips
tiger
oh well it looks like we're both super
now you know I still owe you a whooping
he just got hit by a case in so much
pain you don't have your powers
yeah that's what's going on you just
trying to use us now cause you can't
handle it on your own when one has an
abundance of power
they have a certain duty to use that
power to
[Music]
[Laughter]
what's this farm called the farm upstate
that sounds made up oh yeah well how
would you know I grew up on a farm in a
town called Smallville no that sounds
made up
I'd be happy to take you and your
friends to my farm if you help me save
Superman are you blackmailing me no I'm
just asking you for something which I
will reward you for by not revealing
damaging information
pig to Pig I need your help because my
owner has gotten himself into a bit of a
pickle
afforded by the Justice League Lex
Luthor I actually goes to jail
you have nothing until you've licked
from the cold steel straw power
what
Batman vs guinea pigs
[Music]
[Music]
this ends now sister
she looks great it's a superpower that
every dog possesses even a whack one
like you
oh is that a Band-Aid
vomit's perfume
what's happening sweet cheeks
I ate some green Kryptonite
kryptonians only
loneliness
was in some cheese a dog's only
uh
now just man who's alive
that sounded like a bone breaking
[Laughter]
[Music]
I guess it's down to us I am it's
Justice League sucks just taken out by
guinea pigs remember me when I'm gone
for britsio
that escalated quickly it's krypto's
most powerful move the punch causes a
blast which takes out not only the
villain who gets hit with the blow but
the hero who throws it I sounds like a
terrible power
[Laughter]
crypto is going to kill himself in the
end what an ending for the kids yeah
okay PB think big
[Music]
it's pretty cool
I can't of course you can I mean what's
the worst that could happen I could hurt
someone
or they could hurt me or maybe me
freezing like this is the worst fish
[Laughter]
Turtle use your speed and get them
nicely done this is really about Lex
Luthor don't you understand he was
testing on you we were colleagues we
were scientists
no
look at it Cut's fine but the clarity is
murky as heck face it Wonder Matt you're
too late your boy's getting hitched and
that means
bye-bye dog they don't have an
understanding of how pets work that's it
get rid of the dog
the Hall of Justice
what have you done with Superman
wherever Superman is it's got nothing to
do with me or my company lexcorp
International
foreign what is that voice Kim I can't
Is It Michael Rooker no no I don't think
so
oh that's a hell on Earth right there
quadrupedal land Maniacs have made a
giant mistake messing with a king of
Atlanta oh well hey hold on is that fish
food
doesn't have his powers
[Music]
but those other animals do he's not the
greatest with other animals he better
get it together soon or those ferrets
are gonna take over the world
one more calories Batman
an owner
who was his owner
mom
[Music]
ENT
[Music]
he's so adorable they're so good at like
young animation like the baby head and
like baby dog head little cute
you didn't watch our baby
oh the bite mark
[Music]
oh no
that is so sad that is so messed up so
free that is so sad
[Music]
that breaks my heart and that was like a
long time ago it's a full dog now worst
day of my life but I wouldn't change to
think about it
why not well you love somebody
and I mean you really love them
you got to be willing to do anything for
them you should have let the baby fall
down the stairs that's the lesson here
that's what Heroes do Ace you know what
they say about dogs don't you
never Feed Us chocolate
I love unconditionally
it's just like the least opportune time
for a joke it's really good Striker's
Island she must be going there to Spring
him
not if we get there first come on watch
out for the yeah
invisible jet yep
maybe put up a sign or rope It Off
[Laughter]
it'll be just like riding a bike do you
know how to ride a bike no I know how to
fly
relax we'll be fine
oh [ __ ]
foreign
oh my God yes Spidey cat out of the way
cat child we have to get to Strikers
sorry I can't do that Lulu saved my life
I must take yours
laughs
[Applause]
[Music]
oh man I have a cat just like that yep I
know those cats
PB there's something you should know
about Wonder Woman praise be her name
Diana is fiercely independent completely
her own woman and if you really want to
be like her you'll be yourself
yeah that's a great point
okay pack I have a plan
fast slow down thingy that people do in
movies yes it's Zack Snyder's movie
moment of the year
as voted by real not Bots
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
what's up
[Music]
they know we have that reaction they did
that for us I'm not really an animal guy
oh are you allergic or as a child I fell
into a well filled with bats
hear the screams as their Dark Wings
flapped Around Me scratching my chubby
childless flesh I'm tormented every
waking moment
I really think a pet would be good for
you
oh I can't believe this is finally
happening I can't believe this is
actually happening
now rodent were just defeated by let me
remember it the league of Super Pets
one more step and the puppy gets it
unless your friends walk into those
Stills over there okay I'm gonna count
to three and I'll start at two because
I'm evil two all right Hulu you win no
All Is Lost
let me look at you my pet
it's the only thing
thanks Kryptonite
what a oh dick no that's
what I mean come on you didn't expect me
to share credit with a rodent did you
Share Credit that's your greatest
creation
if I really was his friend I'd have been
there for him no matter what my problem
is me
it is finally being real with yourself
you can't have Justice without truth
thanks Ace nicely done you're flying
what my power says powers back can't let
you keep risking your lives for my
mistake you believe that dope has an
emotional breakthrough gets his powers
back and then bounces I thought it was
sweet sweet too a medium on it
well if I'm honest
[Laughter]
if you told me this song and evil guinea
pigs would be in a movie in 2022 I
wouldn't believe you
foreign
[Laughter]
ah
I'm sending him back to the place from
whence he came from
[Music]
yeah funny story I uh turned my office
into a rocket ship all billionaires have
them it's true
no there's a bomb
on The Rock when it leaves there's this
atmosphere oh it'll implode oh my God
it's so dark
oh
we're just coughing go
not so bad
it's gonna have to save Lois
can't save them both on your own
he's not on his own he's got a family
this pig right here is a fountain
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
I like this whole man of steel framing
yeah
it's a pretty epic finale it really is
crypto yeah
[Music]
yeah well I listened for you
[Music]
face it it's over huh
[Laughter]
Superman is no more and now his precious
little dog is about to do I have
something on my face do I have a pimple
is it wet is it ready should I pop it
[Laughter]
hell yeah
cute ass pets
[Music]
laughs
gone down Lulu
foreign
[Music]
like a brainiac I think so
before Lulu
[Laughter]
[Music]
God damn it Superman gotta keep an eye
on the crib tonight you've done very
poorly in this movie Follow My Lead
Batman works alone
except for Robin and Alfred commissioner
my it crew whoever Morgan Freeman played
whoever Morgan Freeman
this goddamn guinea pig
crypto you gotta go to the Sun
gotta do the Mega Punch
as I destroy everyone you care for and
there's nothing in the world you can do
to stop me
in the world but out of the world
you're right Lulu there's nothing I
could do in this world to stop you what
are you talking about man and why was
your syntax so oddly structured in that
sense
[Music]
if they didn't make solar paw punch they
missed out on an opportunity
oh well you love somebody you got to be
willing to do anything for them
foreign
[Music]
sacrifice
[Music]
Super Saiyan
[Music]
starting
[Music]
oh
my God
somebody step on that guinea pig it's
well overdue you saved my life man
hey well you were in the middle of
saving hours
you know what they say about dogs
so something did get through that super
skull of yours don't make me take it
back
don't eat chocolate never
what have you done to me I'm in hot dog
water aren't I
oh yeah
that's cruel
oh
thank goodness you're okay go away [ __ ]
he's our distance
you make time for your boy crypto I'm
happy for you buddy oh he's grown that's
my crypto rescued me I know the feeling
he rescued me a long time ago oh good
duck
[Laughter]
come here boy
hey
I'm sorry crypto oh
this is a sweet movie
okay one more thing crypto a whole
character
laughs
squishy Bruce that better be a licensed
toy or I will freak
[Music]
hey don't worry I got you
oh my God getting odors wow this is so
weird
so beautiful high-fiving so slow and
we're both really fast huh
Princess Diana of the mascara
[Laughter]
this water guy does hey my name's Keith
Thomas middleditch oh I think it is
sorry I'm not really great with animals
yeah I'm not really great with people
probably because of my traumatic
puppyhood as a child of my family was
taken from me as a puppy I was taken
from my family
what the heck
good boy okay the Batman loves you too
the Batman loves you too
hey Pops yes eat his eyes
never eat chocolate that dog in the
mirror is you
I made some new friends too and now I've
got to bring them to Smallville
I promise him that it would be their new
home
you don't get crypto so precious it's on
good crypto foreign
okay our Intel indicates a dog has been
mutated this could be dangerous we have
to stop him tighten your collars we've
got work to do
I ate the FedEx guy oh no way Super Pets
activate
[Music]
job well done that was adorable that was
very
that was great
it was precious do you know what the
post-credits scene is I haven't seen the
scene but I saw an image because Dwayne
Johnson posted it like the day this
movie came out or something uh I've not
I actually actually don't know what it
is uh now what I do with rock is the two
weeks his movies come out as I unfollen
I re-follow him because he does he does
that and I know that's his marketing I
do not okay I did not know that's part
of it because Hobbs and Shaw he like
gave a lot away and I was like bruh I
actually love this stuff yeah I love
your rock but but I know it's marketing
please stop yeah I'm aware of what
happens in the postground I've only seen
an image but I'm like man why'd you ruin
that rocket yeah no I like started with
hops and Shaw I just unfollow and I
really follow with the neighbors cat in
The Phantom Zone dude this was so cute
this was very adorable movie did not
expect I expected to like it I mean I
was gonna go see it in theaters but I
didn't expect it to be like that well
done yeah it was really it was
surprisingly better scripted than I
thought I mean it's like it's a kids
movie and they have a lot of jokes that
you know obviously are not like not
everything worked not hilarious but when
I was a kid this would have been like a
favorite this would have been perfect
this would have been absolutely perfect
because it's got so much heart it's very
sweet and there's actually like fun
lessons here about letting go and and
learning to be happy for others instead
of letting your own jealousy get in the
way like there's some interesting themes
that I thought it actually did and I was
actually taking it back by oh there's
actually like some real arcs here for
our characters and it's not just I don't
know here's my Association sometimes
with like a Warner Brothers animated
comedy or something with that it would
just be nothing but jokes sure and I I
was surprised by how there was actually
more characters Kate McKinnon is who
this was okay so I was I knew uh to
expect a lot from DC animated like
straight to video like that those are
always incredible but I was a little
worried like you were and then this was
like oh this is as good as those DC
animated but with like a new character
was Diego Luna I didn't know if I was
being racist
I was nowhere close I would never have
gotten there uh MVP for me they got to
do Keanu Reeves they're gonna do Batman
and Ace it was not a single Ben Schwartz
and Thomas middle ditch oh [ __ ] they
just had the best time ever in the booth
they're just like growing out Keanu
Reeves uh I don't think I had a bad line
of dialogue like I I was so happy I wish
there was more of them me too because I
want that movie I want the spin-off of
just them I wish these have done better
are any adorable animals going to let me
out maybe a cat how about a cat nope
let's be honest the two of us are the
real brains behind this operation what
do you say
you want to come live in a studio
apartment
my nails need to be Atrium twice a month
I thought the scene I was talking about
I assumed that The Rock did not spoil
the adoptions uh I really also liked
that there were Easter eggs but it
wasn't distracted I mean that one scene
I was distracted but like overall it
wasn't trying to do too much like it
really lived with the characters we met
right like it didn't try to add 10 more
characters that was distracting Alfred
Molina was jorel David digs with cyborg
okay Dan fogler Sam Levine hey hey
friend of the show wow okay
um a lot of famous stacked cast famous
it's famous names that cast yeah I also
thought the action scenes were really
well yeah they were badass well shot and
like I was on the edge of my seat I was
suspenseful I was suspended I was
suspense I was suspense myself I am a
suspenseful human being but like other
than that so there was a scene that had
like um uh Korg uh and and Ferris and
like a bunch of names that are all like
giant like companies in DC and that was
really clever because they were able to
use their logos that like they were able
to reference Blue Beetle and characters
without having to have them in so like
this would have done really well to have
a sequel and like expand the universe
because they laid groundwork like the
old Marvel phase one did where it was
like you're not looking for 100 things
but you get the Little Seeds I don't
know why this this movie got kind of
like a middling response I don't think
they advertise it very much because I
didn't know it came out until it was out
uh I was aware it was coming out but I
think the response on that I don't know
what people expected from this because
this is exactly this it's a little bit
better than I expected actually I
expected the three to three and a half
this is like a four star for me I really
got a lot out of it yeah it's a solid
family movie and it's it's great for
people like us watching it in the
superhero space and it's also like I
cannot imagine being like 12 to 15. and
this coming out and just like holy crap
maybe maybe nine to fourteen I'm gonna
slide it down one but like imagine being
a kid and just like rocking out to your
your favorite like it's the combination
of pets movies and superhero movies on
paper like this should be a billion
dollars and it's a super adorable film
and well done and eight to 13. I'm Gonna
Keep sliding it's also like pretty
inventive at times like I thought with
like the um the villainous cat I thought
that was Glovers so for the furball
grenade yeah there were so many [ __ ]
that's so pretty that's super creative
and like the the pairings between the
heroes and their characters and then the
pet pets having their own arcs yeah that
mirror the comic book arcs yeah it's
true and I I thought the pets were
mirroring the Justice League too as well
so that way they pair up by the end but
not being one to one like you know
obviously the turtle was but it wasn't
like Batman's the opposite and
vulnerable and that's what makes them
good yeah right like Batman's
vulnerability is his lack of
invulnerability but you also see how
some of the similar you see how they
line up right how they but like the
powers being the opposite but their
characterizations being the same like
that last 20 seconds of them too is like
like that's the movie I want now it's a
sequel I felt like it could have been
like 10 minutes shorter it was a little
longer it was a little slightly at times
over State it's welcome 10 minutes would
have been like a little I think a little
too short it was only a hundred and it
was only 106 or whatever so I think if I
think a nice 97 minute movie yeah it's
the biggest nitpick I'm not even sure
exactly what you would cut right but uh
for the most part though I thought it
was actually sweeping and animation I
was like something you don't get too
deep about it and I think like what is
it that people really wanted it I find
it that funny because yeah it's like to
me it was always Charming even if I
wasn't really laughing I was always
amused by what was happening and I was
never bored by what was happening I also
laugh more than I expected that's the
other part too although I'm a massive
fan of like Dwayne Johnson and Kevin
Hart like them together I love them
together and I was even though it's
voice over and it's like an animated
property they're not playing even humans
they're playing pets I I was expecting
for some more of that to shine through
like the two of them I find that I like
them better in interviews than in movies
I like them better promoting things I do
often binge watch their interviews and
not re-watch any of the videos
[Music]
like I like their videos very truly just
said I'm like I never re-watched their
movies but I always wanted I like
Jumanji but I really like them vibing
more than Jumanji and I like I like I
saw Central Intelligence once and and I
think I just like them they were great
in Central Intelligence but I like them
as friends like I enjoy them I think
their chemistry uh and interviews is
really solid I think them doing the
tortilla challenge is the funniest thing
they've ever done they've some of their
interviews are like some of the best
celebrities anyway I was kind of
expecting a little bit more but I don't
think you can prep that oh look at the
special things we got Greg Rocco one of
the grades George Perez reinvented
Wonder Woman uh love that man so Jeff
Jones everyone's here Marvel Wolfman
finally getting credit for a lot of
characters he did redesign and recreate
in beautiful ways there's also more
Marvel references than I expected them
yeah I thought it was going to be like
we're gonna triple down on medications
yeah all right uh yeah you're right I
expected more meta but instead it was
more like an actual story and it was in
Universe funny yeah it was an actual
story and I thought they would do like
because Warner Brothers lately with
their anime and stuff likes to do like a
lot of these let's turn to the audience
it's kind of nice this was nice to not
be mad you know I love meta it was nice
to live in a universe yeah there was
obviously some meta stuff sure but it
wasn't like Space Jam and you'd like us
fish
[Music]
I haven't actually seen the scene
it's basically exactly like a regular
hero except way cooler you make up your
own rules and then you break them also
you can ignore most moral and ethical
conventions because no one can stop you
[Laughter]
I bet he can't fly to Pluto oh yeah
watch him
[Laughter]
smart to not show his face because he's
the rock
The Rock voiced three people
he voiced the dog he voiced Black Adam
and he voice crypto is Warner Brothers
in the Dwayne Johnson business this
really is the Dwayne Johnson Universe
this is the hierarchy of the DC Universe
about the chains that's what the DC
stands for Dwayne cinematic
extended universe
I mean I don't know if that has any
implications at all I think it was just
a fun little wink at the audience I
think that he's cast us I mean that we
know he's three people in that scene me
because all I saw was the image was
froze behind Black Adam I didn't even
know about the dog I didn't remember the
Black Adam dog um but yeah it was behind
over the shoulder of Dwayne Johnson
looking at Superman and
there were people who were like oh this
really means that he's gonna fight
Superman and it's a setup for that
leading in Black I'm like that is a leap
yeah to me I think it's just after
watching it now it just seems like it's
a wink at the audience because there's
this Black Adam already knows Superman I
I think you're I think you're thinking
small Greg I think that it's Dwayne
Johnson confirming he fights Superman
and then Henry cavill's back but in this
universe also John Krasinski which
confirms the amount of the universe
because Fantastic Four is Reed Richards
and Reed Richards is playing both
Superman and John Krasinski in real life
because Randall is in the one division
show and in the show The Office Randall
played an alternate universe Reed
Richards a la him playing John Krasinski
and being confused that people didn't
recognize him as a joke about who John
Krasinski is and all of this ties into
one giant Universe with the office and
Ricky Gervais is the Godfather of DC
I I definitely listened the whole time
you were talking that's what it confirms
and followed Rick Gervais DC he's there
Kevin feige I saw soups do a video about
it confirmed the phone number
five maybe in the animated format
they're gonna Black Adam and Superman
might find but I'm like this doesn't
even look like they're setting up for a
fight I think they're just not post
credits
like I thought it was a big deal the way
people talked about it I thought I was
like ah massive spoiler you just like
warned me and I was like that's a little
postgres yeah it's like it's a fun
little joke for once I'm not worried
about following the Rock at his movie
released out I love how this is the
actual introduction
PC films though after 11 years this is
the first appearance of Black Adam
that's any and you don't see his face
you don't see his face it's the dog he
actually Superman himself you don't see
his face yeah I know he actually gave
himself the Superman cut I did really
enjoy that one sequence that a mirrored
man of Steel's fight like they did some
really cool choreography that exactly
paralleled the Zack Snyder fight and
steal there was a lot of really clever
like DC film frames that mirrored like
some of the Tim Burton shots and some of
the the Man of Steel like there was a
lot of that cleverness in there whoever
uh I don't know what the equivalent
animation of dping is
um but like I think it is a cinema
because in in Rango one of my favorite
animated films uh Roger deakins shot it
well they shot that differently because
they actually had the action yeah so
when I think of like you know
cinematography it's it's that's how I
actually had Dwayne Johnson on all fours
and then it weirdly joined up on his
back voice in Rango which confirms Black
Adam
uh yeah I got way more than that than I
expected
yeah especially
change the major implications for the
future of the DC Cinematic Universe the
hierarchy has changed that's out of the
month uh yeah that is out yeah this was
the setup this was the tease for Black
Adam what a weird I I really I'm excited
for DC to have like a bow on whatever
they're doing and I personally want them
to keep things in disparate universes I
think this was strong and I think the
strength of DC is not trying to put
everything together but I feel like
every time they try to put like their
pinky and putting it together it's this
like where it's like the first
appearance of Black Adam bro and like
yeah it's it's just well that was before
Kings osloves up then to fix things uh
to save things I just How's that gonna
go I mean I'm just gonna worship zoslov
to the top is that that somebody sells
Warner Brothers
I mean I think uh I I yeah it's true
it's I was watching this look you know
we do a lot of like justice league team
up stuff yeah a lot of references to
such but I don't know I think people the
people who weren't really liking this I
mean if you're one of them sorry I just
think that there's a lot of people who
kind of give this little too much crap
when I'm like what's wrong with this
this is just it's it's really a
straightforward family film was there
well do you remember any of the I
remember a lot of people just being like
uh that it's not funny it goes on too
long it's very funny and that uh what
was the I think people just kind of
because of the DC name was slapped on it
that they kind of just have a a bit more
of an expectation of what they want to
do I I see I'd go the other way I'd say
because the DC name slept on it people
are automatically mad like I don't think
you know what I mean because like it
wasn't horrendously received I didn't
follow because I really I always try to
see stuff before I read so I go into it
like with my take as best I can sure
sure so like this is one of the seven
words I've had muted like super pets I
just didn't want to hear anything want
to have Super Pets
no I was excited for this one dude
that's the movie that uh let's look it
up on Rotten Tomatoes we get a decent
idea what people think maybe I'm way off
in a member Daydreams out that's right
maybe my memory of it is just way off
from two months ago oh no it's got good
feedback
that's really good I wasn't talking
about it you're like the big twist at
the end it was panned by everyone I must
have heard like two reviews and I
thought that's what everyone thought it
just popped up fresh at 88 I was like I
don't know what like no 75 is a pretty
solid score
although it never quite soars DC
Superman's more than satisfactory
Divergent for families in search of
four-legged fun I mean that's certainly
a [ __ ] milk toast review but it was
like enjoyable yeah no I mean I don't
think it's um like you gave it a four I
put in the 80s I put like a I think like
a 75 is pretty solid for me I'd go I'd
go 79 to 82. there we go solid and very
precise calculation therefore for me it
is like yeah it doesn't quite reach like
grandiose animation realm whether in the
style or the storytelling but I think is
a fun cute passable film and but I I
don't really find it like
you know like there's a lot of great
animation movies out there and this
doesn't quite reach a new height for me
of something that's gonna stick with me
or that I'm gonna want to re-watch you
know see I go bell curve right so like
75 is a c and that's average so if it's
slightly above average 79.81 like a b so
so in my scale like so I think we're
we're seeing it the same we just
quantify differently yeah like to me an
80 is like an above average fine movie
got it got it and so like 85 or up is
like exceptional and like I don't put
anything above 95 normally people the
audience score some of the humor might
be too adult for very young viewers what
like what like a turtle trying to sleep
with a helmet the turtle swearing three
times
we live in a purely puritanical Society
if you leave California you will see a
different America this is like dogs
peeing jokes and stuff but dogs don't
pee not in PG movies it's not allowed I
thought it was like very cute I'm
actually looking forward to showing I
don't have any yet but my future
children like I think that's a that's a
movie that'll be really good to
introduce kids to superheroes through
yeah and now reconsider whenever a dog
bites a child that's true maybe the dog
was trying to save the child think twice
about that
marking I'm sorry the dog killed the
child I was trying to save it I first
thought I was trying to save it but it
took me a while to realize never mind
it's mauling your child I gave it three
chances it had the taste for blood and I
couldn't stop it I'm sorry gotta admit
this video is gonna go viral this is
we've done this you can profit off the
death of your child
Greg's filming tick tocks yeah I got to
think of something to do for the river
but yeah anyway a lot of famous people a
lot of great talent super enjoyable
Batman sequel tomorrow I would I really
feel like they are
even though this movie was not a massive
success you can check Box Office Mojo
for me okay never mind
the memory of this film is way it's
about to double check your experience
versus reality real quick
okay 178 million I did not do well
that's not that did not do well
especially
that's just the costume it's good HBO
it's kind of movie that I don't blame
people if you wait for streaming for
this and I feel like it might actually
be better for a rental or streaming yeah
hopefully it picks up because I think
it's worth the experience like I'm
really glad this exists I don't say that
about every movie and honestly you know
the one thing I would say too it's a
real positive is like I'm not familiar
with crypto and Ace and to this to me is
like oh defining you know image for me
like you tell me a crypto and it's like
oh I got a defining memory now of who
they are and I think that's a really
great introduction for these characters
like I've heard the names forever but
I've never dived into anything that has
them so I'm like oh it's actually really
cool to get that flavor you know
especially this deep into superhero
culture right like you're 20 years into
things being mainstream this is and like
animated characters like that are great
for animation yeah I don't necessarily
want to see crypto I know James Gunn
wanted to bring crypto in at one point
did he he wanted to do something with
that's when I first heard about crypto
was like James Gunn like when I started
I should look up who crypto was it was
like oh James Gunn was the one who
wanted to do something you considered a
crypto movie I think when he was being
posted he's familiar yeah yeah oh I
would I would also pay to see that I
immediately take it back give me a live
yeah okay R-rated James good yeah it's a
live action it better be James Gunn
R-rated crypto movie yeah so I think you
know probably grow some likes but I
still feel like even if
even if this even because if you're at
this movie like not even if it did not
do that well in the theaters even though
it didn't do that well in the theaters I
feel like even if they decided a green
green light a Batman and Ace movie and
you had Keanu Reeves and Kevin Hart slap
those names on there that trailer I
think that because I did find myself
craving more Keanu Reeves and the
marketing for this movie made you think
you get more keanuary because every line
was gold it was so good and there were
trailers like dedicated just to the
Batman Keanu Reeves and he's legit like
the great characterization of that dark
brooding but he's barely in barely he's
barely in it and I feel like if they
green light that movie people would show
up it also might retroactively help this
one yeah no totally because you've
already got the animation like um done
for the character types like yeah I'm
not saying it's done I'm saying like
you're halfway to a new movie because
you had like the Will Arnett who was the
pompous arrogant cocky version and then
you would have you know um Keanu Reeves
who's just fun email
yeah that's part of the poking Jabs at
him but it's Keanu Reeves who does a
great job I think you should green light
that movie Warner Brothers yeah I'd
watch that tomorrow and you just got him
on Constantine too he's in the house
yeah make it happen he's available I
need to make sure because erections
everyone loves it all right guys leave
your thoughts down below was DC League
of Super Pets uh an abysmal failure like
everyone has been saying everyone or
leave your thoughts down below follow
koi subscribe click that Bell leave a
like catch you all soon
[Music]